now i'm not a fella to pass a quick
judgment
but i've been around long enough to know
you don't hire a saint
to catch a sinner
red dead redemption 2 is a game about
consequences with the illusion of choice
yes there are some decisions to be made
and those decisions will shape your
character in the world around you
but some of the game's most disastrous
choices were made before it even begins
leaving you to deal with the fallout and
because it's a prequel to red dead
redemption you also
probably know how the story ends all
that's left is discovering what happens
in between
and making the most of it to that end
you fight against cyclical missions
frequent moral dilemmas and the
inconvenience of doing what's right
i'll see what i can do for the most part
the frustration that can cause is also
what makes the story impactful
and when it all comes together the
effort is not wasted we have all made
mistakes over the years hosea
every last one of us but i kept us
together kept us alive kept the nooses
off our neck
at the beginning of red dead redemption
2 the vanderlin gang is already on the
decline we know is coming
after a heist gone wrong in blackwater
they're on the run down a few members
and on the verge of capture starvation
or succumbing to a snowstorm
there are familiar faces red dead
redemption protagonist john marston
chief among them
as well as new ones i love you arthur
morgan
i love you come on take a shot come on
take your best shot please
as senior member arthur morgan you're in
the privileged position of being dutch
vanderlin's right hand privy to his
machinations and included in the most
important outings once the gang escapes
the storm and settles into a temporary
campsite you're also put in charge of
the camp's finances meaning you pick out
all the upgrades and supplies
if dutch is the center of the gang
arthur is adjacent to all its vital
parts at once and that gives you a lot
of power at least at first
with that power you're encouraged to do
as you see fit a lengthy series of
missions early on introduces you to some
of the ways you can spend your time
including hunting
fishing horse rearing and robbery give
me all you got mister
there are a lot of systems and covering
the basics takes several hours
while they're not so cleverly disguised
as to not feel like tutorials the actual
learning is paced well in its
integration with the story and the
missions also acquaint you with the
characters and surrounding area
for example the fishing tutorial has you
taking jon's young son jack out for the
day since his father is not great
at fatherhood jack is pure and sweet and
incredibly vulnerable to all the gang's
wrongdoings and the mission is memorable
for it
now cast your line swing the rod
back over your shoulder and bring it
forward in a smooth motion
there are also elements of semi-realism
you have to contend with though they're
not always as successfully woven into
the story
you need to eat to refill your health
stamina and dead-eye cores and eating
too much or too little results in weight
changes and various consequences
eating itself isn't a problem but eating
enough to maintain an average weight is
intrusive and not worth offsetting the
hit you'll take to your stats
you don't have to sleep and surviving
hot or cold temperatures comes down to
choosing the right outfit from your item
wheel so weight maintenance
sticks out as superfluous
[Music]
there's next to no fast travel at the
beginning and your options are limited
in general so you have to rely on your
horse to get around
it can be slow but there's no shortage
of things to do and see on the way
please someone show kindness
on a man with no sign chance encounters
are plentiful
you might find a stranger in need of a
ride to town or a snakebite victim who
needs someone to suck the venom out of
their
wound you can stumble upon a grotesque
murder scene that sets you entirely off
track or you can see someone in danger
and just keep riding
and just as you can decide to rob or
kill most anyone you'll also run into
people who will do the same to you
even the longest rides aren't wasted
time and it's hard not to feel like
you're missing something if you do take
a shortcut
red dead redemption 2's version of
america is wide open stretching from
snowy mountains in the great plains down
to the original games new austin in the
southwest
further to the east is the louisiana
inspired deep south which is still
feeling the effects of the civil war
after nearly 40 years
there's a distinct shift going from
region to region as grassy hillsides
become alligator-filled swamps union
veterans give way to angry confederate
holdouts and good intentions and casual
racism turn into desperation and
outright bigotry
the world both reacts to you and changes
independently of your involvement
buildings will go up as time goes on
and some of the people you talk to will
remember you for better or
hey friend worse me yeah
that's the guy yeah hey this
this here's the fella the one that found
me
this fella you let him suck on your leg
incidental moments as you explore make
up a large part of the morality system
in which you gain and lose honor based
on your actions
good morals are relative you're a gang
member after all
but generally it's more honorable to
punch up rather than down
helping an underdog even if they're an
escaped convict and even if you need to
kill some cops or robbers to do it nets
you good guy points
in these situations it's easier and
cheaper to be noble than a true outlaw
committing a crime with no possible
justification is hard to do undetected
and usually requires you to track down
and threaten a witness run and hide from
the law or pay a bounty down the line
high honor on the other hand gets you a
pretty discount at shops
in many ways you're nudged toward
playing a good arthur
the gang members he's closest to from
the beginning are the more righteous
principled ones who are motivated by
loyalty and a desire to help others
while he insults argues with and
generally reacts negatively to those who
are hot-headed and vicious but it's now
or never then it's never the most rotten
of them is micah who's so easy to hate
that it's hard not to follow arthur's
lead and take the higher road
had a good time did you you going to get
me out of here
i ain't decided yet real funny oh i
ain't joking cowpoke
i heard so much bluster out of your
mouth these last six months
and now i got an opportunity to watch
you
be silent unlocking camp upgrades like
one-way fast travel and better supplies
also essentially forces you into being
honorable
although everyone donates you have to
invest hundreds of dollars yourself if
you want to afford anything
and that automatically gets you a ton of
honor points whether you like it or not
it's a lot harder to feel like a good
guy when doing the main story missions
though
arthur along with nearly everyone else
is loyal to the gang first and foremost
this means following dutch into trouble
busting friends out of jail and
committing a number of robberies in the
interest of getting money for the gang
even if you're trying your hardest to be
good you'll inevitably slaughter entire
towns and mandatory story missions
stealth and non-lethal takedowns aren't
always an option and the snappy auto
lock aim makes shootouts a far easier
option anyway
this is fun for you the dissonance is
frustrating to play through but that
frustration is incredibly important to
arthur's arc
as well as your understanding of the
gang as a whole that extends to the
structure of story missions which start
to get predictable around halfway
through the game
it's not that they're boring the
opposite is true actually and you see a
lot of action from beat to beat but
after a while a pattern emerges and it's
easy to figure out how any given heist
or raid is going to go
this too becomes frustrating partially
because you often have no way of making
things turn out the way you'd like them
to
but your weariness is also arthur's and
that's crucial
and there's enough variety between
missions and free roam exploration to
prevent it from dragging to the point of
being a chore to play
[Music]
like any good prequel there's an
incredible amount of tension in knowing
what
happens without knowing exactly how if
you played red dead redemption
you know who lives and as a result who
probably won't make it to the end of
this game
even during the slower parts you're
waiting for betrayals and injuries and
other events you've only vaguely heard
mention of before
you're waiting for characters to reveal
their true selves and watching as
everything unravels is riveting and
heartbreaking if you know what's to come
you can still enjoy the story in its own
right without that background knowledge
though
javier and charles i've missed you
and bill looking as well as can be
gentlemen always a pleasure
some of red dead redemption 2's best
moments have almost no relation to its
predecessor
one mission takes you to a women's
suffrage rally and a painful side
mission has you facing a woman whose
husband you killed and life you ruined
what are you looking at thomas i said
what you looking at woman my husband
isn't well
if we could just have more like i said
we ain't nobody's idea of charity get us
the money
the new characters are among the best
sadie adler is a personal favorite for
reasons i won't spoil
another a young black man in the gang
named lenny mentions how the southerners
treat him a little differently
arthur says that he hasn't noticed
anything weird to which lenny replies
all respect mr morgan you wouldn't
notice
while red dead redemption was mostly
focused on john marston's story
red dead 2 is about the entire vanderlin
gang as a community
as an idea and as the death rattle of
the wild west it is about arthur 2 but
as the lens with which you view the gang
his very personal very messy story
supports a larger tale
that tale is also supported by sometimes
frustrating gameplay mechanics and a
predictable mission structure but
without that frustration
the story would lose its impact this
place
ain't no such thing as civilized
it's man so in love with greed
he has forgotten himself and found
only appetites red dead redemption 2 is
an excellent prequel but it's also an
emotional thought-provoking story in its
own right
and it's a world that is hard to leave
when it's done
[Music]
you